When Spider-Man officially joined the MCU
back in 2015, fans were understandably excited
about the prospect of seeing some classic
comic book villains finally get some silver
screen love.
Those fans got exactly what they wanted too,
with the Vulture appearing as the main antagonist
in Spider-Man: Homecoming, alongside classic
foes like Shocker and the Tinkerer, shortly
followed by Mysterio in Spider-Man: Far from
Home.
Meanwhile, Sony Pictures has attempted to
develop a handful of other Spider-Man villains
into their own independent projects, starting
with 2018's Venom and continuing with the
upcoming Jared Leto flick Morbius.
So far, most of the other Sony Pictures projects,
such as Silver & Black and a solo Mysterio
film, appear to have vanished into the ether
— but one project that's supposedly still
a go is the standalone Kraven the Hunter movie.
Fans have long wanted to see the nefarious
big game hunter on the big screen, but there
hasn't been all that much news about the project
in recent months.
A 2020 report from Deadline suggested that
J.C. Chandor was in talks to direct, with
a script by Equalizer scribe Richard Wenk,
but that was the most recent major development…
until now.
That's because, according to a recent rumor
shared by The Illuminerdi, Marvel has allegedly
made a formal offer to Keanu Reeves for the
role of Kraven in his own standalone movie.
To be clear, neither Sony nor Marvel have
responded to this rumor, so you're best taking
it with a massive grain of salt.
But if true, it would be the biggest development
for the Kraven the Hunter movie to date.
On top of their potential casting scoop, the
rumor site also reported that the tone of
the film will be a mix of Man on Fire and
Logan.
The Illuminerdi stressed that this is only
an offer so far, however, and didn't give
any indication of whether Reeves has accepted
or not.
On at least one level, though, it is absolutely
true that Marvel Studios has courted Reeves
for a number of projects.
In 2019, Marvel president Kevin Feige told
ComicBook.com that many discussions with Reeves
had taken place, and that:
"I don't know when, if, or ever he'll join
the MCU, but we very much want to figure out
the right way to do it."
And while it would make sense that Sony might
want to nab a big star in the role, it's also
unclear whether Kraven would be the Marvel
character Reeves would finally want to pick
— particularly since the connection between
Sony's standalone flicks and the MCU remains
unclear.
Regardless, if Reeves were being courted for
this notoriously over-the-top character, it
would be an entirely different beast from
the kind of roles he's generally associated
with.
It's worth saying again that this is a totally
unsubstantiated rumor, and neither Marvel
nor Reeves have commented on it.
Indeed, one reason to be skeptical is that
it's unclear whether the standalone film is
moving forward at all, or if Sony is waiting
to see how Morbius fares, or — even more
confusingly — whether Kraven might instead
appear in an MCU Spider-Man movie.
After all, it was said that Sony was pursuing
that solo Mysterio film back in 2017, but
the character instead appeared in Far From
Home.
And then there's Reeves himself, who's a busy
guy to say the least.
Among the most prominent of his upcoming projects
include The Matrix 4 in December 2021 and
John Wick 4 in May 2022.
"Yeah, I'm thinking I'm back."
After that, he'll be appearing in a fifth
John Wick film.
He's also involved with two more upcoming
films, Rally Car and Past Midnight, as well
as the TV series Rain.
Sony hasn't officially confirmed their Kraven
movie is happening at all, much less shared
a timetable for the project, but if filming
was to take place before 2023, Reeves would
have a difficult time fitting it into his
schedule — especially given the heavy demands
of featuring in a Marvel film.
And given how difficult it's been to bring
Reeves into the Marvel fold thus far, it might
not be time to bust out the Kraven cosplay
just yet.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.